[Music]
take a seat let's do this show right
Andy yeah now that someone showed a
picture of the Pope what look look at
that sign there just says I'm Catholic -
wow I'm so sorry that's a rough way to
grow I know I never see you paired with
the Pope enough though I'm glad that
somebody finally my mom's gonna love
that yeah yeah I saw you on the TV with
the Pope that's exactly how my mom talks
yeah you're a good boy
today is Yom Kippur yeah that's right
Yom Kippur Yom Kippur is the day when
Jewish people ask for forgiveness nice
yeah
of course for my people that would be
the day after st. Patrick's Day I do
like that one huh
she puts her sign away he's one of us
know a lot of world leaders in New York
City right now for the UN bash is that
what it's called I don't know it I've
just fainted UN leaders in New York yeah
true story iranian President Mahmoud
Ahmadinejad gave a big speech at the UN
today and he was actually applauded yeah
of course he uh he did start his speech
by saying these replacement refs suck
crowd went crazy
they went singing for it there's baby
suck it's true it's it's being reported
that the NFL is close to reaching a deal
with the refs yeah and the replacement
refs say they're very close to finding
their ass with a map and a compass
course I always loved that fake by the
way right
I can find my ass with a map and a cop
right right Mitt Romney working very
hard to close the gap with Obama it's
rumored that in a recent Univision
interview MIT Romney wore dark makeup to
appeal to Latino voters
yeah I don't know about you but I can't
wait to see Romney's appearance on BET's
[Applause]
an airline in Asia announced its selling
seats in what they call the quiet zone
where babies are not allowed yeah yeah
the the people most likely to purchase
seats in the quiet zone are businessmen
and parents of babies
I would so get see the quiet tonight
yeah put my kids in the luggage rack
I've done it before and it's not illegal
yeah it's fine yeah it's fine there's
enough air TLC ladies and gentlemen TLC
has ordered more episodes of here comes
honey boo boo
yeah just as the Mayans predicted it
said that that's the sign
make your arrangements now I got to
mention this at a recent concert Madonna
told the audience she would strip naked
if President Obama is re-elected yeah in
a related story President Obama is now
trailing in the polls by 97% these days
when Madonna strips everybody's poll
goes down
[Applause]
I'm so sorry he still happy it took the
picture of the Pope here to the show
[Laughter]
what you said